DAGEN McDOWELL.
"THE FIVE"."
THE VILLAGE IDIOT HAS SPOKEN.
FORMER BILL CLINTON SPOKESMAN
AND SPUTTERING WACKO DOODLE JOE
LOCKHART SUGGESTS THAT UNDER NO
CIRCUMSTANCES SHOULD JOE BIDEN
DEBATE DONALD TRUMP.
YOU ARE THINKING IT MUST BE A
GAG.
NO, ACCORDING TO LOCKHART, TRUMP
TELLS SO MANY LIES IT’S
POINTLESS FOR BIDEN TO ENTER THE
RING WITH SOMEONE WHO CAN’T
FOLLOW THE RULES OR THE TRUTH
BUT YOU KNOW HE’S REALLY SAYING.
THE MOMENT BIDEN FACES OFF WITH
TRUMP AND THE COGNITION STARTS
MALFUNCTIONING, HE’S DONE WHICH
IS REALLY WHY LOCKHART ADMITS
BIDEN CAN LOSE THE ELECTION.
HE’S CREATING A PHONY REASON
HOPING NO ONE NOTICES BUT WE
DID.
HE IN THE CAMPAIGN CREATE A FAKE
MORAL LOOPHOLE FOR BIDEN TO WORM
HIS WAY OUT OF SO HE WON’T TANK
IN PUBLIC.
OH, WE CERTAINLY CAN’T DEBATE
TRUMP.
HE FIBS.
HE WEARS HAIR PLUGS.
WAIT, THAT’S JOE.
IF THAT’S THE STANDARD FOR ALL
CANDIDATES, WE NEVER HAVE
ANOTHER DEBATE EVER.
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WOULD BE AS
THIN AS I AM IN ONLY HALF AS
HANDSOME.
ALSO WOULDN’T YOU WANT TO DEBATE
A LIAR BECAUSE YOU COULD COME
ARMED WITH FACTS.
CLEARLY IF JOE CAN’T HANDLE A
DEBATE, HOW CAN HANDLE BEING
PRESIDENT?
WOULDN’T HIS FEEBLE ACT
DISQUALIFY HIM?
MAKES YOU WONDER IF HE REALLY IS
THE ACTUAL CANDIDATE AT ALL.
YOU CAN SEE LOCKHART DIDN’T
THINK THIS THROUGH WHICH IS WHY
HE WRITES FOR CNN.
AND IT SAYS SOMETHING THAT A
MEDIA COMPANY, ONE THAT J.J. BE
IN TRANSPARENCY AND SO ON, WOULD
PUSH THE PUBLIC FORUM TO
EVALUATE THE CANDIDATE IN
REAL-TIME.
IT MUST BE COOL TO HAVE FRIENDS
IN HIGH PLACES OR AT CNN, LOW
PLACES TOO.
ALL RIGHT.
DANA, I SAID THIS WAS COMING.
I SAID IT WAS COMING.
I BELIEVE HE’S NOT GOING TO
DEBATE DONALD TRUMP.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> Dana: I HAVE TAKEN THE
OTHER SIDE OF IT AND IN FACT I
THINK I PLACED A PRETTY HEFTY
BET WITH TUCKER CARLSON.
I AM ANXIOUSLY AWAITING TO SEE
IF I’M GOING TO HAVE TO PAY UP.
THE OTHER THING IS JOE LOCKHART
IS NOT AVERSE TO SAY THIS.
THE REASON I HAD THE BEST WITH
TUCKER CARLSON IS ABOUT FIVE
WEEKS AGO TOM FRIEDMAN,
COLUMNIST FOR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WROTE A
PIECE ALSO SAYING THAT JOE BIDEN
SHOULD NOT DEBATE.
THE CAMPAIGN THAT JOE BIDEN IS
GOING TO DEBATE.
TRUMP HAS SAID HE WANTS MORE
DEBATES AND EARLIER.
INCUMBENTS USUALLY DON’T WANT
THAT.
THEY USUALLY ARE LIKE, WE ARE
NOT GOING TO BOTHER WITH THAT
BECAUSE INCUMBENTS ARE IN A
PRETTY STRONG POSITION.
WANTING TO DEBATE MORE SHOWS
PRESIDENT TRUMP LOVE TO DEBATE,
WANTS TO BE OUT THERE AND WANTS
TO BE ABLE TO SAY THIS IS MY
RECORD AND THIS OUT IS WHAT I
WANT TO DO.
HE DOESN’T WANTED TO BE A
REFERENDUM ON HIS RECORD THOUGH
I’M SURE THEY’RE GOING TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT BUT THEY
WANTED TO BE A CHOICE BETWEEN
TWO PEOPLE LIKE HE DID WITH
HILLARY CLINTON AND HE DREW THAT
DISTINCTION QUITE WELL AND HE
WANTS TO DO THE SAME WITH BIDEN
WHICH IS BEEN A LITTLE BIT HARD
TO DO WITH THE CAMPAIGNING
CORONAVIRUS.
>> Greg: YOU NEED TO HAVE A
PERSON.
TO DRAW THE DISTINCTION AND
THERE IS NO PERSON THERE, DANA.
ALSO WE DON’T CONDONE GAMBLING
AT FOX NEWS.
IF AFTER THE SHOW YOU COULD GO
TO THE H.R. DEPARTMENT AND
THEY’LL PROBABLY HAVE YOU FILL
OUT SOME FORMS.
MARIE, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
IF JOE BIDEN DOESN’T DEBATE, HOW
CAN WE EVEN CONSIDER HIM WORTHY
OF BEING PRESIDENT?
>> Marie: GRAN, BIDEN IS GOING
TO DEBATE.
BIDEN WANTS TO DEBATE
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE OF ALL
THOSE LIES, BECAUSE OF THE
FAILED RECORD HE WILL ARGUE.
ALL OF PRESIDENT TRUMP’S
SUPPORTERS WERE SETTING THE BAR
SO LOW FOR JOE BIDEN, EVEN YOU
JUST DID IT IN YOUR MONOLOGUE,
SING ONCE HE STARTS TALKING
IT’LL BE CLEAR HE’S NO GOOD.
THAT’S NOT A HIGH BAR FOR BIDEN
TO LEAP OVER.
HE NEEDS TO SHOW AMERICA HE CAN
PUT TOGETHER FOUR SENTENCES AND
I’M CONFIDENT HE CAN PUT
TOGETHER MORE THAN THAT.
YOU ARE SETTING THE BAR SO LOW
FOR JOE BIDEN THAT BE CAREFUL.
HE IS GOING TO FLY RIGHT OVER IT
IT.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND I LOVE LOW BARS.
JESSE, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
DO YOU THINK HE’S GOING TO
DEBATE?
>> Jesse: YOU LIKE BARS,
DOESN’T MATTER HOW HIGH OR LOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS REMINDS ME
OF, THE GUY WHO ALWAYS CLAIMS HE
IS A REALLY HOT GIRLFRIEND BUT
FOR SOME REASON YOU NEVER REALLY
GET TO MEET HER.
HE’S ALWAYS SHOWING YOU PICTURES
OF HOW GOOD-LOOKING SHE IS BUT
EVERY TIME THERE’S A PARTY,
OTHERS TRAVEL PROBLEMS OR SHE
HAD TO STAY LEAD WORK OR OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
THIS IS JOE.
EVERY TIME THERE’S GOING TO BE A
BIG -- OH, PANDEMIC.
HAVE TO STAY IN MY BASEMENT.
THE GLOVES ARE GOING TO COME
OFF.
NO, STAY IN THE BASEMENT IS
WORKING.
OH, MAYBE I’LL DO AN INTERVIEW
WITH THE SWALLOWS.
SCHEDULING CONFLICT.
MAYBE JOE IS GOING TO TAKE SOME
QUESTIONS.
SORRY, GOT TO RUN.
GOING TO DEBATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
ACTUALLY TRUMP CHEATS.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
SEEMS LIKE THE JOE BIDEN
CANDIDACY MAY BE THIS BIG MIRAGE
BECAUSE I DON’T KNOW ABOUT YOU.
WE LIVE IN A DEEP BLUE STATE.
I GO TO THE WEEKENDS.
I GO TO JERSEY, AND OTHER DEEP
BLUE STATE.
I HAVEN’T SEEN ONE JOE FLAIG,
T-SHIRT, BUMPER STICKER.
YOU GO ON SOCIAL MEDIA, THERE’S
NO POPULAR JOE BIDEN ACCOUNT.
EVEN THE MEDIA IS NOT PRO-BIDEN.
THEY ARE JUST ANTI-TRUMP.
SO BIDEN MUST BE COMATOSE IF
THEY ARE FLOATING THIS TRIAL
BALLOON.
OR THE EXPECTATIONS ARE SO LOW
THAT HE HAS TO HAVE LIKE
SOMETHING SHORT OF A MEDICAL
EPISODE FOR THEM TO CLAIM HE’S
DOING WELL.
HE IS RUSTY.
THE LAST TIME HE DEBATED A
REPUBLICAN WAS EIGHT YEARS AGO.
HE DEBATED PAUL RYAN ONCE.
SO WHAT I REALLY THINK IT IS,
THEY KNOW JOE DOESN’T HAVE A
QUICK ENOUGH WITH TWO WIN THOSE
MEMORABLE EXCHANGES THAT MAKE
THESE MODERN-DAY TELEVISED
PRESIDENTIAL DEBATES.
THE PEOPLE CLOSEST TO JOE JUST
DO NOT HAVE THE CONFIDENCE IN
HIM.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU DEFINED
IT.
THE JOE BIDEN CAMPAIGN IS THE
CANADIAN GIRLFRIEND CANDIDACY.
THE GUY WHO ALWAYS HAS A
CANADIAN GIRLFRIEND.
YOU NEVER SEE HER BECAUSE SHE’S
ALWAYS IN CANADA SOMEWHERE.
HEY, DAGEN, I WANT TO PLAY YOU
SOME OF BILL STEPIAN.
RULE WITH TEETH, IF YOU WILL.
>> I WANT TO SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP
ON THE DEBATE STAGE AGAINST
JOE BIDEN.
YOU ARE NOTING, WE ARE SEEING
THE LIBERAL LEFT, THE LIBERAL
MEDIA, TRYING TO CREATE
TRAPDOORS FOR JOE BIDEN TO
ESCAPE HIS COMMITMENT AND HIS
OBLIGATION TO DEBATE
DONALD TRUMP ON A DEBATE STAGE
IN FRONT OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE WANT MORE DEBATES.
>> Greg: FIRST OF ALL, I
CONGRATULATE THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ON HIRING TEENAGERS.
I SWEAR THAT KID CAN’T BE MORE
THAN 14.
DAGEN, WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
I BELIEVE THERE IS A STRATEGY
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO ONLY DO
ONE DEBATE.
THEY DON’T WANT TO DO MORE THAN
ONE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Dagen: AT LEAST ONE DEBATE
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN’S AT THAT
PLACE OF HIS LIFE WHERE MOST
FAMILIES WOULD START HAVING
THOSE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT TAKING
HIS CAR KEYS AWAY FROM HIM.
GO OUT AND LOOK AND SEE IF THE
REARVIEW MIRRORS ARE MISSING OFF
HIS CAR.
JOE BIDEN HAS TO PROVE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE HE CAN GET UP ON
THE WHEEL SO TO SPEAK.
ED ROLLINS, TO BILL STEPIAN’S
POINT, HAS ALWAYS SAID JOE BIDEN
HAS A GLASS JAW AND HE NEEDS TO
BE ABLE TO LAUNCH AND QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE DEALINGS OF HIS SON,
HUNTER BIDEN IN UKRAINE AND IN
CHINA WHICH IS THE GREATEST
THREAT TO NOT ONLY THE
UNITED STATES BUT THE WORLD AT
THIS POINT.
SO FAR, BIDEN’S BEST COME BACK
ON THAT NOTE HAS BEEN LOOK,
HERE’S THE DEAL, WHEN FACED WITH